[Music]
now then helping people with their
energy bills and rising food costs will
not add to inflation that's according to
one of the uk's most prominent business
leaders tony danker who's head of the
confederation of british industry spoke
after the chancellor rishi sunak
promised tax cuts for businesses if they
invest more to try to boost the uk's
economy so should the government be
doing more to help workers and families
with the cost of living crisis well in a
moment i'm going to be joined by a
personal finance expert and an economist
to talk about the future of this crisis
and how to deal with it plus several
people really feeling the squeeze on
their incomes but first the rising cost
of gas and electricity has of course
left some families forced to choose
between heating and eating and for some
switching off could be the difference
between life and death quite literally
katrina vittotsi reports
open the curtains
so
so show them where your oxygen is
when alex was born his mom was told he
wouldn't live beyond a week
he is now a thriving 16 year old but
needs near constant support
at night an oxygen machine keeps him
alive
during the day a pump provides vital
food water and medicine
just let me swap your feed round please
first
everything is run off batteries and
mains power
bills just go up and up i would probably
say an extra 300 pound a month
just in
in household bills and things for alex
it's a case of life and death obviously
because he's on his oxygen machine
overnight so
if we couldn't literally afford
to pay those bills then
i don't know what would happen
this is the stark situation faced by
families with sick and disabled children
at home as energy prices rise they
simply can't unplug it worries me for
the future as to
if things do get worse
how
how will it affect us as a family um
what what do we do kind of thing because
it's all very well and good somebody
coming and saying go and get an extra
job or do this and do that but alex
alone is a full-time job i feel like
it's a constant battle with a child with
a disability
and it never stops
[Music]
it's incredibly hard
sorry
much needed respite comes from here this
centre was set up by emma and other
local parents it's been entirely built
and funded by the community
it's support at the end of the day and
there's not much of it around
you know at the minute it doesn't do me
any good staying on the outside not
hearing me all the time
even though i didn't love you very much
these children and their families dearly
need this help
they worry as prices rise and budgets
tighten it will become harder to find
well let's discuss the overall cost of
living in crisis now what might be done
about it here in the studio with me is
laura suter head of personal finance
with aj bell and shreyander an economist
at the institute for public policy
research center for economic justice
who's also worked for the government
economic service welcome to you all
we're also joined this evening by
throughout the programme we'll be
talking to
michael atwell bryce who is a foster
parent and full-time carer to 15 year
old twin boys with his partner paul and
from south london we're joined by carly
newman who is a single mother on
universal credit very good evening to
you all and uh michael let's hear from
you first of all about um a bit about
your life and the and the fostering and
the
the young teenagers that you're looking
after and and some of these these
pressures and and i suspect of course as
for so many millions of people energy
and food loom large
yeah definitely so we used to spend
about 130 pounds
a month on energy and we're being told
by his energy provider now it's going to
be
one thousand it's gonna be five thousand
pound just under five thousand pound for
a year so that's gone up massively uh
obviously there's two older twins levi
and lucas they're disabled um we go to
the hospital a lot with them fuel in the
band's gone from like 80 pounds 220
pound a week um it's just it's just
skyrocketing like beyond being able to
manage it it's just getting so expensive
where we have to cut back on other
things and what about the boys they um
teenage boys well we we know how often
they raid the fridge
oh yeah i mean
we've got five children all together so
we've got four boys of his own that
we've adopted uh two sets of twins and
then we've got a foster child as well as
15 and they're always obviously hungry
wanting feeding um but it's it's mainly
the energy and and the fuel um more than
the food to us because as all the boys
have got life threatening and epilepsy
and um they've also got autism so a lot
of their stuff's electric the beds are
plugged in they've got special uh
equipment sensory equipment which is
over enough electric
so it's not that worries us the most and
that's i mean obviously the specialist
equipment really burns up the
electricity as well do you get any
specific help for that
no so obviously like everybody else
we've just started the hundred and fifty
pound rebate off the council tax cuts
we're in that certain bar
but to go from like one thousand five
hundred pounds a year for gas and
electric to five thousand and obviously
that's not going to even touch the sides
it's not even going to make a dent in it
so
it i mean
and then if it's going to go up again in
october
it's like their epileptial arms are
plugged in the beds are plugged into
electric sensory equipment is the baths
like a hydrotherapy bath they've got an
electric changing bench we've got like a
through floor lift to take us from
ground to first floor if they have bad
seizures so everything's run off that we
can't we can't turn on that off we can't
stop using none of that type of stuff
it's not like just turning the lights
off with stuff that they really need for
their medical needs definitely is
michael i'm going to put some of those
concerns then to our experts and carly
well i i know you're nodding along there
many of the same concerns there about
energy prices but um
laura i mean what can be done is
michael's saying there right so we've
got this help announced in the spring
statement
to to deal the government thinks with
the situation as it is now on energy but
prices are just going up and up and it
may last months years
i think when the government first
announced that um bit of support in the
form of the council tax rebate but also
the 200 pound energy loan scheme that's
coming in later this year um they were
basing it on
the energy price spike being temporary
and also on the price rises that we saw
already this year what we're now looking
at is october there's going to be
another increase with some people
expecting that average household bills
are going to go up to around 2 600
pounds a year now obviously for
that's an average family um if you've
got more people in your household or if
you've got particular needs then your
energy costs are going to be far higher
and i think we're now at the point where
the government can't do nothing anymore
there are so many families and
households out there that are struggling
that i think the weight of public
opinion is such that they will have to
do something and before october i think
what we've heard so far because that's
when a new price cap will be set yeah so
october is when the nation will see
their energy prices rise again um
i think it's almost impossible now for
the government to wait until october
they we've heard this commentary from
rishi sunak saying he stands ready um i
think at this point the nation is saying
we need you to not just be ready but do
something shreya give us the overview
though on energy is it necessarily going
to continue to rise because you know we
we know about the war in ukraine and the
effect that that's having on gas
supplies in particular to europe yet we
hear the governments and all governments
talking about diversification getting uh
getting away particularly from these
carbon fuels but that presumably is
going to take years may not necessarily
be cheaper yeah i think that's right we
when we look at the global situation we
yes it's the stuff that's happening in
ukraine but we also see cascade effects
in in energy and food markets around the
world so what's happening in india with
wheat exports what's happening in sri
lanka with their food situation so it's
possible that the problem could get
worse and then in terms of what the
government's doing to diversify energy
supplies obviously that's that's really
necessary but i think what we've seen as
a response from the sector is that
that's not going far enough and they
really need to be throwing the kitchen
sink at this and putting everything into
increasing supplies so that we can get
through the winter without seeing yeah
but but just in this winter and maybe
next winter michael just come back on us
because of course being floated around
here and it's one of labor's main
policies is a windfall tax on these
energy companies because of the soaring
price of all their fuels they're making
these huge profits billions upon
billions would you like to see them hand
some of it over to help out people like
you
definitely i don't understand why this
can make millions and millions of pounds
and then millions obviously put that on
yeah billions of pounds and put it on to
families like us i know like lots of
families get in touch with us because we
do a podcast about disabilities as well
and we get in touch with different
people with special needs and stuff and
they're all struggling they're having to
turn sensory equipment off the they're
trying to cut back on going out on trips
to the parks with the children in the in
the like we've got a special wave so
it's a wheelchair accessible van and
that takes a lot of fuel to fill so
what these children like levin lucas
disabled children they're going to be
losing out the most because it's the
carers they're at home a lot it just
costs a lot more to do it
yeah certainly that's right what about a
windfall tax then i mean clearly the
energy companies can afford it it's
happened to them before
you say the government's got to throw
the kitchen sink at it surely well this
is at least part of it this is a couple
of taps or something yeah i completely
agree we should be looking at measures
like windfall tax um as you say energy
companies are making huge profits and if
we think back to when companies like
british gas were privatized there
weren't the provisions put in place to
deal with the situation like this where
we see massive profits but really high
energy bills for consumers and that
that's something that should have been
done then and needs to be done now but
laura the the argument is okay even if
you do do it it may not be enough it's
it's a one-off you can't keep doing it
you will deter investment and of course
i i know that there's a there is an
effect on people's pension funds a lot
of people don't know that they're
invested and get huge amounts of money
from these companies if they're paying
windfall taxes then there's less in
dividends going to those pensioners but
will it be enough or will it just
symbolize something yeah i think partly
it's that symbolic thing of the the
nation being quite angry that these
companies are making so much money and
they feel like they're taking the money
out of their back pockets and making
profits directly from that so i think
it's partly the weight of public opinion
it will help obviously it will raise
money we don't know exactly how much
until um the government commits to it
and says how much it would what that
exact windfall tax would be we don't
know how much it would raise but it
would go some way to helping people
it would then depend how the government
used that money if they were to funnel
it to the lowest income families and
those most in need then obviously the
cost the the amount per head that you
would get would be much higher if they
handed out a slightly broader measure
like the council tax rebate where lots
of people got that i mean i got that and
i'm certainly not in a low-income family
so it's not targeted not targeted enough
um and so if it went to that and went to
more households then the actual amount
that you'd get per household wouldn't
this 200 quid is i mean it's a loan
ultimately it's going to come off your
bills in the future exactly so it's a
loan that you pay back at a rate of 50
pounds a year now obviously that loan
might help some people to get through
winter and it's a no-interest loan so
it's much better than people who would
otherwise be putting that on high-cost
debt but it's not uh it's not a handout
it's the government lending you a bit of
money for a bit of time you're still
paying it back certainly not the kitchen
sink let's hear from carly carly welcome
to you thank you very much indeed for
joining us now you are a single parent
so what we'd like to hear is i suppose
you know your household balance sheet
just simply your income versus your
expenditure how um they're diverging i
suppose
yeah i guess um for me there's uh that
obviously we've been talking about
energy and food but i live in london so
i have very high rent costs and very
high child care costs to balance as well
um and and you know i've always had them
so it feels like
the the cost of living crisis isn't in
isolation of um very high costs that
i've already been sort of seeing um
so i
work in a fairly um senior role
upper management but i do still rely on
universal credit
in order to
and be able to meet those costs
particularly around rent and child care
um
and i work slightly less hours um in
order to sort of practically manage my
childcare but also financially because
it's so expensive um and and that's
where the sort of like shortfall comes
and i rely on universal credit but
obviously as we know universal credit
the hasn't risen um in line with in
inflation so yeah yeah so
basically right energy we know about
rent
gone up and clearly food you know where
are the stresses and strains in the
budget for you
um so um
yeah as we were talking about before
energy definitely my energy bills at the
moment are the same price as they were
in like winter uh last year so i
normally see a decrease by about 50
percent in the summer or the the warmer
months i'm not seeing those now
they're the same price as winter
um and and yeah food like shopping just
just general living um is is just
becoming more and more um expensive and
more and more inaffordable and um it
yeah it just feels like where do we get
to live so we're we're working more
we're being told to work more
um and work harder to to be able to
manage that but we can't do anything
because um it's so affordable yeah work
more or get a better job
how easy is that um just tell us though
you don't have to give us the numbers
just the proportions then between your
income from work and your income from
universal credit
um you mean versus just the just the
proportions what is it two thirds from
work and a top-up from universal credit
of about a third is it kind of like that
yes yeah it's about yeah that is about
right yeah yeah yeah all right um let's
talk then uh to laura and shreya and
laura first of all i mean universal
credit you were talking earlier about
how targeted benefits can be i mean the
one thing that the government took away
post pandemic was this 20 pounds uplift
on universal credit surely if they just
left that alone many people
like carly wouldn't be in this situation
yeah so we've had the the fact that they
took that away and also as kali alluded
to there the fact that the benefits
haven't increased by the current rate of
inflation so they increased by a
previous inflation figure that now looks
very out today out of date in comparison
to the price rises that we're seeing so
if you think about that in terms of a
pay rise people haven't had a pay rise
to keep up with the rising cost of
living and so that means they have not
enough money to meet those bills or less
money so is there a case for
just tell me how the timetable works the
uh off the top of my head so we get the
inflation numbers from september which
then are a flood a pr applied to
benefits and pensions in the subsequent
april that's a long time to work what
about if they just did it you get the
numbers this september the right month
you get the inflation numbers then and
then just do it in october just give
people the nine or ten percent whatever
inflation is by then yeah there's just
exactly as you say there's a big time
lag between the inflation figure they
take and when it actually comes in now
there's been a lot of talk this week
about the archaic government systems and
the fact that they need that time period
to bake in those increases put them into
their systems but it feels slightly mad
that in the current times that we're in
that it would take so long for them to
update that and that's also part of the
argument that the chancellor is putting
forward for not having a kind of
mid-year increase in those benefits
that's something that's been suggested
is bringing forward next year's increase
in benefits so people benefit now but he
blames outdated systems for not being
able to do that well yeah well or
perhaps lack of lack of cash which is
what i want to put to you share two big
picture questions first of all the the
outlook for inflation wouldn't it be
great if um some of the bank of
england's predictions from last year or
that it's transitory did come to pass it
looks like it's pretty baked in at the
moment and still going up
yeah i mean the bank of england has said
that they think that 80 of inflation is
to do with energy and food price shock
so that's like supply-side shocks from
things like the ukraine crisis so that
is on the transitory side rather than
the the idea that the economy is
overheating due to high demand but we
they are expecting inflation to stay
high for most of the rest of this year
so there is a real need for the
government to do more to make sure that
ordinary people aren't having to choose
between heating and eating as you said
earlier
and what about the issue can the
government afford it i mean huge amounts
hundreds of billions spent on lockdowns
and supporting businesses and
individuals during the pandemic
presumably they can only go
so far if this is a cost of living
crisis for years to come
does there come a point when the
government can't afford it when we as a
nation can't afford it well on the one
hand there is that as you say high
spending during the coveted pandemic but
then on the other hand there's things
like the record energy company profits
that we've seen the
huge gains that asset owners have made
during the pandemic they've seen their
wealth go up enormously so we do need to
consider both of those things when we
think about what the government can
afford and then if we look over the last
10 years we've seen you know a pretty
stagnant economy huge amounts of
unprecedented monetary policy action to
keep the economy just where it is so i
think the way of thinking where we're
like oh the government can't afford to
do this they can't afford to do that
needs to we need to rethink that yeah
but i mean then the really big picture
question this is global isn't it it's
caused by a multitude of factors we've
got war we've got lockdowns in china
we've got raging inflation in the united
states so many other problems
it doesn't look like it's going to end
any time soon
and then yes it's to do with global
factors but then how we respond to that
is within our gift like france has
enough domestic energy to capacity to
meet its needs and therefore it was able
to do to take much stronger action than
we were on making sure that consumer
prices stayed low so what we need to do
is make that investment in things like
nuclear power solar power wind power
retrofitting gas reservoir capacity so
that when the next crisis comes we can
do that as well when the next crisis
comes back we're in one now let's get
back to carly carly just tell us a
little bit though about family life you
talked about rent there you're in london
you're from london you're charles from
london i suspect you've got you know
friends and relatives nearby
could economic factors force you out
um everyone asks me this
um i won't leave london um because my
parents live in london um all my friends
as a single parent it's kind of
essential to me that i am near them
and i think that's sort of more
important for me and my son so i i won't
leave london but it does become harder
and harder to to live here for sure okay
and you've got uh a specific question
haven't you um
for our panelists carly
um well i i i had a few
but you you've got one then you
give us your main one
um i guess um
my main question would be around i think
the fact that so far it's felt like the
government's response has very much been
about
blaming and trying to get us as
individuals to take responsibility
um
without them taking any responsibility
themselves and and the things that
they're suggesting feel very unfair and
unrealistic so
what could and should the government be
doing you know what could we be
asking them and lobbying them to do more
of i guess specifically because it feels
like the sort of blame and expectation
is all on us as individuals and that
feels um very unfair and unrealistic
that's an interesting point carly thank
you for putting it i mean laura what do
you make of that do you think that
the government is trying to you know
point at the public point of the
individuals and say you can't work hard
or you can can get a better job and not
doing enough itself
i think that's a fair criticism i think
um at the start of this when i think the
government thought this might be more
transitory to use that um terrible
phrase uh they thought that if they put
more on individuals to cut your energy
usage make your home more energy
efficient
cut your food shop then we might get
through this period now it's obviously a
much longer period it's not transitory
and so i think then it's on us to push
that back onto the government and um
see what they could do and so many great
suggestions have been put out by um
great experts like shreya and other
people in terms of what the government
could do the costings of that they're
not short of ideas i think it's for them
working out what they can afford and
what they're willing to afford but are
they we may be straying into politics
here shreya you know they seem to say
one thing and then say something else uh
you know at the same time you know where
uh we're cutting taxes but they're also
actually putting up taxes we had the
chance to say that to businesses we know
corporation taxes going up they're
saying that about um national insurance
contributions
they haven't really got their act
together have they no and if you look at
the recent spring statement our analysis
suggested that they gave four times as
much support to richer households as
poor households so we they need to be
taking a different distributional
approach to their support and they need
to be doing more to target support at
ordinary and low-income households okay
listen we're we're joined uh very
quickly now by uh lizelle bramel who we
hope to talk to earlier but lisa we had
a few problems with your link you're a
hairdresser and a farmer nice mix uh
just give us the view uh economic view
quickly if you can from the field and
the town
well um i'm a small business owner and
it's getting increasing heart to harder
and harder every week
to make ends meet once your uh
your rent's going up your petrol to get
in just to get to work
your national insurance contributions
are all going up you've got pensions to
pay holiday pay electricity going up
stocks increasing every every weekly
and then there's a shortage of products
as well uh we have a lot of products
from italy
and they're just hard to get their own
that's quite a list as i say
unfortunately because of our
communications issues uh the time is
limited give us one question for our
panelists
from your point of view you know from
from i guess from working on the high
street
yeah how do you get the eye straight
back to its best and when people have so
much to pay out how do you get people
back on the streets
that is a very very good question and i
suppose it's also a post pandemic
question um what are your thoughts on
that how do you get people back into the
town centers and that is having a big
economic effect of course isn't it yeah
and i think that's a big issue in that
um if you've got this cost of living
crunch and you've got people
making a choice between heating and
eating as we've talked about um they're
not going to be popping to the high
street to wander around the shops and
make some impulse purchases they're not
going to be going out to restaurants and
bars those are the kind of easy cuts
that people can make um
when they're looking at really rising
bills and so i yeah i think that's
difficult one thing that the government
could do is cut um vat which it did
during the pandemic um it cut vat for
hospitality businesses now that did help
a lot of businesses not a lot of people
consumers it's not sorry we're out of
time i'm so so sorry laura suta shreya
nanda lizel brahmal michael atwell bryce
and carly newman thank you all very much
indeed more coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you